new media rockstars we implore you to go
back and check out the mythical show
yeah 30 minutes is not a long time but
now 30 times 12 is 6 hours but that's
math we don't worry about that 1/4 of a
day don't go to school you know I should
do you should not go to school you
should play hooky hooky something cause
all these people are professionals to
read I mean these are not just students
you should not go to work you should not
go to life you should quit your job and
you should watch it our show marathon
well rhettandlink is a creative
collective consisting of two people me
link and this guy Rhett I carry most of
the weight I feel like if we could
describe what we do in a few words we
would probably know what to do every day
we come here it's nice to having done so
many different things as we've kind of
grown our audience that anything's fair
game now whether we're good at all those
things is still questionable I think I'm
good I think a big part of it is that
we've always kind of worked towards the
same thing are you about to say
something moving
no well you might cry make me cry right
that's not my intention early on we did
we kind of decided that we were going to
work together in fact we were in middle
school middle school or early high
school when we did that blood oath thing
this is serious yeah we did a blood oath
early high school we went to a cow
pasture and we wrote out an oath and
then we signed it in our own blood there
were two copies as with any covenant
yeah and then we kept each of them in
our wallets until like I lost my wallet
and then your you know don't keep up
with things I lost my like three days
later but we remember the blood oath
that we had to create something together
it's like we're gonna make something big
together that's like with the language
that was very sincere
it was very sincere but it's also very
ambiguous because it was like right
we're gonna either nothing together
maybe we should redo it like I can't
find it by renewing a marriage of how
kind of thing I think that that's always
sort of the thing that kind of keeps us
focused and cuz we work really well
together but there is a there's a
there's a lot of disagreement a lot of
arguing that gets kind of part of our
creative process just kind of part of
the way we work together that I think
that if we you know it that's the key to
it kind of going for so long it's just
always kind of having
go things are getting hairy got a minute
my unibrow first music videos in May was
called the unibrow song it's about the
unibrow that we had and how to deal with
him that was featured on the YouTube
homepage and then we started to realize
that we could kind of develop an
audience based around our YouTube videos
and not just us goofing off and hey by
the way let's just throw it on the
internet and so we started building that
audience but then like you said we got
the call one day from a television
producer who said hey we're making a
show it's basically a clip show of
Internet videos but it's gonna be on
television called online nation we want
to use a couple of your clips and we
ended up hosting that show long story
short we ended up hosting that show when
we began hosting that show we were like
alright we're gonna be in the
entertainment industry full time the
show got canceled and we were like
alright well we've got the Internet so
let's put everything we've got into this
YouTube channel and that was when we
began making very regular videos you
know almost weekly and you know it was
very very slow going for at least a year
of making these videos and living off
that little money that we made in the
television show and starting to think
well how is all this gonna come together
and eventually it got to the point we
started making video sponsored videos
and that was kind of the beginning of
our business model this is before the
partner program you know before you
could actually just get paid by putting
a video up on YouTube we had to approach
companies directly and say hey we've got
an idea you've got a brand that would
work well for this let's do something
together and then of course following
that up with a partner program and now
we continue to do sponsored videos I
mean that's this has kind of become our
business it's just making online content
for our channel our two channels and
occasionally for for other other places
too we do we don't do one thing I think
that doing a lot of different genres of
video I mean so it's always funny you
know we don't do any videos that aren't
funny or at least they're all supposed
to be funny I think the key to having
longevity for us has definitely been the
diversity of our content and it also
it's easier to come up with ideas when
pretty much anything that might be funny
to us it might be funny to our audience
keep going our channel it's kind of a
catch-22 because doing a lot of
different things is very rarely gonna
make you really popular on on on YouTube
and I think we've kind of we've
maintained a great fan base but like
link said we're not on the top 100
anymore I don't know if we ever will be
Alan think that's our goal necessarily
most of the people who are in those top
positions was like oh yeah the guy that
does this thing and does it really well
but it but I you know I know the people
who do that kind of thing and they want
to do other things too it's like nobody
wants to do the same thing all the time
so it's kind of a blessing and curse but
I think the key to the longevity is just
the diversity of content the mythical
show kind of created this challenge for
us to be like how can we put together
everything that we've done in something
and can we build an audience around that
and I think the jury is still kind of
out on how you know well people have
responded to it I think people who watch
it really love it but it's still and
this is why YouTube's willing to
innovate in this area it's still it's
not the kind of thing that people make a
decision to watch on YouTube they make a
decision to watch the 3 to 5 minute
video
yeah people don't people don't think
about YouTube as oh I'm gonna sit down
and watch a show for 30 minutes in the
way that they think about Hulu or the
way that they think about Netflix the
way that I think about Netflix and Hulu
you know I've even had to kind of shift
my perspective in order to watch my own
show we wanted to do the show because we
wanted to be some of the first people to
say once it does happen
once there is more and more long-form on
YouTube I want people to say oh you want
to know one of the first shows that did
that go back and watch run links
mythical show and you'll see what they
tried way back in 2013 we learned a
whole lot we produce more content in a
shorter period of time than we ever have
we have so many so much new content we
learned so much with an animated show I
mean we probably went five times like
our normal production oh yeah we sing
some of Taylor Swift's most popular
songs and let YouTube's automatic closed
caption tool translate them
yeah so machine me didn't never pay now
if you just look at it from a financial
perspective it makes a lot more sense
and dollars for us to make those
individual pieces of content that you
would expect not only from us but from a
YouTube viewing experience but I mean we
place a premium on innovating and saying
okay we're some of the first people
trying this particular thing and helping
blazed a trail and to change people's
mindset as they approach a YouTube video
you know it means a lot to us to be
those people who've innovated it just
doesn't it doesn't translate into as
much money on the front end so I kind of
see it as an investment and kind of the
future of YouTube and YouTube was
willing to invest in us because they
want that to be part of their future
when you do this kind of thing for a
living when you create entertainment for
a living you're not just doing it just
to do something that's financially
viable because that's just you know
you'll lose yourself really quickly in
that and it'll get very boring and
monotonous very quickly we have to do
things that challenge us creatively the
kinds of things that we're into
personally the kinds of things that we
would enjoy personally are the kinds of
things that you won't continue to make
and that this the challenge of making a
feature-length film is something that we
want to do hopefully there will be some
sort of financial strategy so we don't
like lose money and maybe we'll make a
lot of money if it works but it's really
more about the creative process and
trying to be strategic creatively not
just financially we have our audience
here online you know we did a television
show that took us away for almost a year
a lot of our audience online couldn't
see the show commercial Kings on IFC it
was frustrating being able to come back
and kind of realign with our audience
and connect with them and create things
that engage us and engage them I think I
mean that's our main strategy that's our
the realist we haven't made any specific
plans for what we're doing next well
though because the one thing that we
haven't been able to do while making a
musical show is sit down and just think
and I think that's a big part of what we
do is we sit down we think we talk we
have desks that face one another as
crazy as that sounds because we you know
our creative process involves balancing
things off of each other until it
becomes something that we both like like
this like I don't really that close idea
we're like like give me an idea like say
idea back to me idea one idea to becomes
idea three so my response to idea 3
becomes idea 1 again that's more
exciting than that once we get back from
vacation that's what we're gonna be
doing yet we're gonna be we're gonna be
saying idea one idea tied it to it idea
3 back into 4th until some until we're
like oh yeah let's do that
there's the what's the most strategic
you know for remaining relevant on
YouTube because that's a question that
every YouTube creator has to ask
themselves and we're not above that
question we are trying to maintain and
build an audience on YouTube and so
that's always gonna be part of the
conversation and then there's the how
can we challenge ourselves creatively
sometimes those things go hand in hand
you know sometimes the answer to those
questions is the same and you can move
forward sometimes it's like well we got
to work on this because it's challenging
and we've got to do this because it's
gonna maintain an audience and you know
having those conversations and kind of
figuring out whether that's plan of
attack is but I will say this you know
the first few episodes of the mythical
show there was a lot of backlash that we
weren't doing good mythical morning
again I think for the fans of good
mythical morning we had taken away their
cereal you know I get up I give them a
frosted mini-wheats and I get my good
mythical morning you've taken that away
I hate you rhett and Link what is this
mythical show 30 minutes is just once a
week got a lot of that we also got why
do you have a studio audience
that sucks so episode 2 we killed the
studio audience literally everyone who
was in the audience we murdered we heard
oh and welcome so episode 312 there is
no studio audience because we're you
know we developed the mythical show in
response to her audience but the one
thing we couldn't do was stop the
mythical show and keep and just go back
to good mythical morning because we were
committed to doing something new so I'm
happy that here we are at the final
episode of season 1 of the mythical show
and I see in the comments now there's
still that discussion of people saying I
can't wait for good mythical morning to
come back and other people to say yeah
but I love the mythical show people are
audience seeing them as two distinct
entities now that should not necessarily
be compared to one another as Fahim
'only as they had been so now I see that
both are on the table to come back at
different times and and the things that
we've learned from the mythical show I
think whenever we do relaunch good
mythical morning which will probably be
a component of the next thing we do it
will be informed by everything we've
learned it's such an accelerated pace in
the production of the mythical show and
then you know there's gonna be a third
thing which if it has the word mythical
in the title would just become even more
confusing and compared to the other
things it was quite cooler than another
word thanks for watching our interview
now this video has been truncated
there's lots of things that we said that
I'm not gonna say they were amazing but
they were written down and if for some
reason you want to know everything is it
everything the whole transcript yeah new
media rockstars calm now you can read it
they won't include the facial
expressions that I was making that
really enhanced this whole interview
that won't be in the notes but just
picture me I think my stomach started
growling at one point that's not gonna
be in there you shut up you could have
heard it